sale temps pour les médias en gang est
visé par de multiples poursuites
judiciaires cette réalisatrice vient
d'écoper d'une amende
l'accusé d'avoir consulté des registres
publics sous de faux motifs selon les
autorités c'est que le sujet de son
reportage d' enquête
l'attaqué de militants pro démocratie
par des partisans pro-gouvernementaux
dérange et ce magnat de la presse
jimmy nay célèbre bête noire de pékin a
vu ses journaux puis son bureau privé
perquisitionné il est actuellement en
prison il a été condamné comme de
nombreux militants pro démocratie pour
son rôle dans les grandes manifestations
de 2019
les violences qui ont émaillé ces
rassemblements a largement pacifiques
ont servi de prétexte à la chine pour
serrer la vis avec une loi sur la
sécurité nationale nécessaire selon les
autorités pour rétablir la paix et la
stabilité dans les territoires
semi-autonomes
en vertu de cette loi jimmy l'ail est
aussi accusé de collusion avec des
puissances étrangères
car il a sollicité une mobilisation
internationale contre la répression du
mouvement pro démocratie constat de la
profession c'est pire que ce que l'on
craignait pour la liberté de la presse
et pour la liberté en général affirme se
reporter il reproche à la loi d'être
trop vague donc sujette à interprétation
et aux autorités d'être très agressive
et fret
un vent d'intimidation souffle sur toute
la presse et résultats dit il
il ya encore plus d'auto censure et
journaliste marche sur des oeufs
déjà en plein débat sur la loi sur la
sécurité nationale
cette populaire émission satirique
headliner avait baissé le rideau
retirée après 31 ans d'antenne à la
radio-télévision publique rthk
un sketch sur la police avait déplu
l'existence des missions comme et leur
permet de mesurer la tolérance des
autorités face aux critiques la scène
l'un des producteurs et acteurs
les autorités contrôlent désormais la
rthk
faisant fi de son indépendance
éditoriale pas évident dans ce climat
d'enseigner le journalisme à hong kong
nous disons à nos étudiants que le
travail des médias est protégé par
l'état de droit mais les événements des
derniers mois semble indiquer le
contraire en ce professeur l'exécutif
hongkongais pro pékin et veut maintenant
légiférer contre les fausses nouvelles
dont il est selon lui la principale
victime
chris young estime que cela pourrait
entraîner un risque de manipulation et
de nouvelles pressions sur les médias
indépendants
il ajoute que pékin tient le gros bout
du bâton ici annick bureaud radio canada
montréal